au stade des quarts de finale une seule
épéistes régional en piste la
chalonnaise
aline chevalier elle tire devant son
public opposé à la guadeloupéenne est là
qu avait nous sommes ici dans la
troisième et dernière manche est là que
la vie a remporté la 1ère 5 touche à
rien mais a perdu la seconde cinq
touches à une c'est finalement aline
chevalier qui s'impose 6 touches à 5 à
hinch vallier qui affronte en demi
finale une autre guadeloupéenne laura
flessel mais cette fois la réussite
n'est pas au rendez vous la chalonnaise
va s'incliner deux manches à zéro
rien à faire mais bon sur et de la
troisième ça fait la différence la plus
entraînements les meilleurs quand le
fait de jouer comme ça devant son public
à chalon c'est dur en dehors de la piste
oui mais une fois qu'on arrive sur la
piste n'a pas gêné en finale face à la
nordiste marie-céline ogoda laura
flessel va flancher dans la première
manche avant de gagner la seconde il
faut là encore une belle pour départager
les deux jeunes filles laura flessel va
l'emporter 5 touches à trois très
contente et puis ça prouve qu'au niveau
de la guadeloupe le travail on a
continué à travailler quoi là maintenant
nous sommes arrivés après la victoire
l'explosion de joie pour ce premier
titre de championne de france junior le
raf les sectes comme la chalonnaise
aline le chevalier n'a désormais plus
d'ambition préparer les prochains
championnats du monde
[Musique]